ich bin gleich da ich muss noch was zu trinken holen so was zu trinken geholt ich muss ich
muss aufpassen heute ich habe das handy von der arbeit hier liegen es könnte sein dass
ich angerufen werde weil was kaputt ist ich habe jetzt moment ich muss mal mein netz entwirren was
ist das hier guckt euch das war nicht zeit aber wartet mal was man auf kabel kabel champ
auf kabel champ so hätte entwirrt ja es könnte sein dass ich angerufen werde leute garmin uhr
stellt die ziehe ich jetzt mal aus ist verwirrend weil er könnte sehen was für krasse pulsfrequenz
ich hier habe guck mal massive pulsfrequenz weil ich mit der chatte
der chat nicht so nervös macht guck mal sieht man hier was ja 85 gerade im stehen davor wetter
temperatur liegt ja wie gesagt es könnte sein dass ich angerufen werde ich habe das handy hier
neben dran liegen ist auch auf laut falls irgendwas kaputt geht aber ich rechne nicht damit weil unsere
systeme laufen insgesamt doch relativ stabil aber es kann halt immer was sein und wisst ihr
ich habe jetzt sechs tage in folge bereitschaft und davon jetzt haltet euch fest und davon ist ein
feiertag und das wochenende das heißt das gibt wahrscheinlich auf einen schlag jetzt also ohne
steuern ohne steuern steuern muss ich darauf bezahlen das gibt wahrscheinlich auf einen
schlag jetzt ungefähr 1800 euro brutto richtig richtig pepo bernmann hier pepo bernmann die
gibt's ihm da mache ich gerne sechs tage bereitschaft du hast schon 21 tage ja ich
hoffe die bezahlen das auch ordentlich weil sonst ist das pepo sad da wo ich bin kriegst du das
ordentlich bezahlt deswegen haben die leute auch kein problem damit bereitschaft zu machen weil
ich hätte auch keinen bock drauf wenn hups ich bin ja ein kack noob hierher ich hätte längst
schon wieder umschalten müssen warum geht das umschalten ihr nicht richtig guck mal ich muss
schon ausschalten das ist ein elgato backe sagt war nämlich gerade mal arzt bei the way package
updates und nachdem wir jetzt rast machen quality ist destiny peitschein will auch geupdatet werden
nachdem als rast machen installieren wir mal wieder eine runde rust rover und heute ich zeige euch das
gleich nachdem ich rebooted habe ja das ist nice dann lohnt sich das dann lohnt sich das ja wenigstens dann lohnt sich das ja wenigstens
da gibt es fette stրx Das ist aber nix super competitive das ist eher so solving
f stern abfreut sich 49 freut sich richtig bei mir das freut sich quasi schon also nicht nur das
finanzamt freut sich der steuerberater freut sich auch die freuen sich schon seit jahren
Und seit ich mit meinem YouTube-Stells angefangen habe, freuen die sich.
Und die sind doch immer so nett.
Die lassen mir immer, wenn sie Briefe schicken, sieben Tage Zeit zum Bezahlen.
Das ist sehr freundlich von denen.
Weil die könnten ja dir auch nur 24 Stunden Zeit lassen.
Aber ganze sieben Tage lassen die dir Zeit.
Mit inklusive Rechtsbelehrung hinten drauf.
Das ist schon sehr zuvorkommend von denen, dass sie einem sieben Tage Zeit lassen.
Das ist übrigens auch egal, ob du im Urlaub bist oder nicht.
Sieben Tage sind sieben Tage.
Ist sehr nett, finde ich auch.
So, Kernel-Update.
Bam.
Michael Fuffenspieler hat eine sehr gute Idee, aber ich habe gerade was getrunken.
Seit wann denn das?
Ist das neu?
Also ich bin angemeldet mit einem Fake-Account hier im Streaming-Dings.
Nicht mit Wobblors.
Ist das neu?
Oder Modgis, falls Modgis da sind.
Haben wir das irgendwie, irgendwas Spezielles eingeschaltet?
Auf der anderen Seite, wahrscheinlich hat so gut wie jeder normale Zuschauer,
ein verifiziertes Konto.
Und dementsprechend passt das.
Das schließt wahrscheinlich die ganzen, meine Nacktfotos im Profil, Spam-Accounts aus.
Ja, das ist sehr nett.
Ja Leute, ich mache jetzt mal hier, ich schalte mal kurz um.
Was ist denn das für ein Scheiß?
Warum geht denn das Elgato-Zeug hier nicht richtig?
Anzeige, direkt.
Chat, ihr müsst mir mal sagen, wie es besser ist.
Und zwar so.
Also hier, ne.
Hallo, Leute.
Was geht?
Sagen wir mal, ob das so besser ist.
Oder, ich mache mal kurz, ich mache mal Color-Correction aus.
Oder so.
So ist, so ist ein bisschen, ein bisschen dunkel und ein bisschen zu, ein bisschen zu rot, finde ich.
Ja?
Wie findet ihr es besser?
Wie gesagt, die hellere Variante oder die dunklere Variante?
Es gibt auch noch die Möglichkeit, die, die helle, ne.
Es gibt auch noch die Möglichkeit, ich kann auch die Color-Correction,
einfach ein bisschen runter machen, so auf irgendwie sowas hier.
Irgendwie so.
Jetzt können wir nochmal uns hier dazwischen umschalten.
Ja.
Ich glaube, so ist auch, so ist, so ist, glaube ich, ganz okay.
Nicht so das, nicht so das, nicht so das Extreme.
Ja.
So, so sieht, so sieht, ja.
Das ist alles ein bisschen rot, ne.
Egal.
Ist schon okay so.
Wobei, das, das passt eigentlich echt.
Ganz gut jetzt.
Guckt mal, Leute.
Ich hab gar nicht mehr.
Kennt ihr noch die alten Videos?
Ich hab letztens so ein Video geguckt, wo, wo ja so das, so der Running-Gag war.
Äh, Max hat dicke Arme und so.
Guckt mal, ich hab gar nicht mehr so, so dicke, so dicke Arme.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ist gar nicht mehr so dick.
Nicht mehr so dick wie früher.
Ich zieh die Uhr mal aus.
Braucht keiner hier.
Ellbogen liegt, ja.
Und Finger auch nicht mehr im Vergleich zu früher, äh.
Die sehen, ne, vergleicht das mal mit früher, Leute.
Das ist, das ist wirklich, die Finger sind gar nicht mehr so dick im Vergleich zu früher.
Nacktfoto sind Profil, ja, endlich.
Das liegt am Licht und dass ich tatsächlich, guck mal, hier oben sieht man es.
Da, wo die Uhr ist, guck mal.
Da, wo die, man sieht den Unterschied, guck mal.
Hier ist die Uhr immer und hier ist der Handschuh und hier ist das Normale vom Arm.
Also man sieht genau, bis wohin ich irgendwas anhab.
Hier ist die Normale Farbe, die ab und zu Sonne abkriegt.
Und hier Handschuhe und hier halt Uhr, ja.
Guck, hier siehst du auch, hier, hier, Lücke, Lücke vom Handschuh, Uhr.
Schiebst du aus Mexiko?
Wer weiß.
Der Osten meldet sich zurück.
Ne, Moment.
Mexiko ist im Westen von uns.
Falsche Himmelsrichtung.
Egal, wenn man lang genug im Westen geht, kommt man im Osten raus.
Also ich habe mir folgendes überlegt heute, was wir mal ausprobieren können.
Und zwar, ich mache mal den Keks weg.
Der liegt nämlich etwas im Weg.
Der ist zu pipo-fett.
Also was ich mir überlegt habe, ist folgendes.
Wir probieren mal aus, ein ESP32 zu programmieren mit Rust.
Weil ich habe dieses Projekt hier gefunden.
Guckt mal.
Jetzt habe ich meine Kiste neu gestartet.
Ja, also das Elgato.
Zeug ist echt ein bisschen buggy.
Das muss man immer ein- und ausblenden, dass es funktioniert.
Guckt mal.
Ich habe das hier.
Ja, nicht AliExpress.
ESP, äh, S.
Das gibt ein Github-Projekt.
Oder was ist ein Projekt?
Eine Orga ist das, glaube ich.
Ja, Orgs, genau.
Auf Github.
Die haben versucht, quasi das, was du standardmäßig machen kannst, mit C++.
Also C.
Und C++ für den ESP32, soweit kompatibel zu bauen, dass man das mit Rust programmieren kann.
Also sprich, die haben auch alle möglichen Schnittstellen drin.
Ich habe das, und das muss ich dabei sagen, ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert.
Go gibt es auch, aber TinyGo hat, glaube ich, richtig Probleme.
Also zumindest habe ich mit das letzte Mal geguckt.
Und da gibt es zum Beispiel, ich glaube, hier gibt es ein Beispiel drin.
Wir müssen gleich mal gucken, wie wir das installiert kriegen.
So, so sieht zum Beispiel ein Hello World in Rust aus, was aktuell nur über den Konsolen-Debugger irgendwas ausgibt.
Was ich habe immer, einfach ausprobieren.
Ich habe gar nichts vor.
Aber ich habe mir überlegt, ich habe mir ein interessantes ESP32-Board rausgesucht zum Ausprobieren.
Ich habe ja gefühlt richtige ESP32-Sammlung hier.
Und zwar, umschalten, wenn es gehen würde, wäre sehr nice.
Und zwar habe ich mir überlegt, wir probieren das mal mit folgendem Board aus.
Und zwar habe ich nämlich hier noch ein, ich packe das mal aus.
Und zwar habe ich hier noch, da kann man nämlich ein paar Sachen mit ausprobieren.
Ah geil, geht wieder.
Guck mal, man kann es auch einfach da oben an dem Ding aufreißen, wofür es gedacht ist.
Ist auch nicht schlecht.
So, und zwar habe ich noch ein frisches, ist schon ein bisschen älteres Board.
Aber das ist ja, generell ist der ESP32 auch eine relativ alte Plattform mittlerweile.
Da kann man aber...
unterwegs davon ausgehen, dass es funktioniert.
Und zwar, guckt mal, ich habe noch ein Hitigo T-Display gefunden.
Das heißt, wir können ausprobieren.
Man sieht es hier, warte mal, ich muss kurz abputzen, das sieht ein bisschen dreckig aus.
Es kommt einfach so dreckig aus der Packung.
Anzeige.
Kurz putzen.
Ja.
Und zwar ist das ein ESP32-Board mit einem Display.
Das heißt, wir können jetzt hier ausprobieren.
Mehrere Sachen.
Ah, ist jo, danke schön.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Wir können jetzt hier mehrere Sachen ausprobieren.
Oh, ich sehe gerade, es hat gerade keine Pins für das Spreadboard.
Da müssen wir das schnell noch, müssen wir die hier noch schnell dran...
Löt-champen.
Dann funktioniert das auch.
Genau, das ist nämlich ein ganz nettes Board.
Das hat hier oben sogar einen Button.
Das eine ist hardcoded.
Der Reset-Button oder der Flash-Button.
Ich bin gar nicht ganz sicher.
Müssen wir mal nachgucken.
Und eins ist ein Button, den braucht man zum Flashen.
Nee, der Reset-Button.
Reset-Button ist hardcoded, genau.
Und eins ist ein Flash-Button, den man aber im normalen Betrieb, glaube ich,
auch als ganz normalen Push-Button verwenden kann.
Wir haben ein Display und wir haben ein paar ganz, ja, normale GPIO-Pins.
Ich ziehe mal hier das Ding ein.
Ach, deswegen sah das so kacke aus auf dem Display.
So ist es natürlich viel besser.
Da habe ich die Schutzhülle mal abgezogen.
Also da können wir mal gucken, ob sowas etwa...
Oh, das ist USB-C.
Das ist ein USB-C-Board.
Muss ich gleich mal gucken, ob ich ein halbwegs langes USB-C-Kabel irgendwo habe.
Habe ich bestimmt noch.
Muss ich mal gleich suchen.
USB-C, weil ich muss ja mit...
Ich muss das mit einer Verlängerung machen.
Ich muss ja quasi von hier dann hier rüber, so zwei Meter, einen USB-Anschluss von meinem Computer.
Sirius Max, Prox Subscription.
Danke, Leute.
Also wir können ein paar advancedere Sachen machen.
Wir können mal gucken, ob es in Rust möglich ist, nicht nur Hello World auszugeben,
sondern hier drauf auf dem Display was anzuzeigen.
Und dann können wir mal gucken, ob das...
Das wird bestimmt richtig eklig in Rust.
Ich habe das irgendwie schon so im Gefühl.
Und dann habe ich noch ein paar andere Sachen am Start, die wir ausprobieren können.
Ich habe einen Luftfeuchtigkeit-Temperatursensor.
Und ich habe so einen Bewegungssensor, den wir mal ausprobieren können.
Und dann habe ich noch den Klassiker, falls wir das machen wollen.
Können wir theoretisch wahrscheinlich sogar mal mit anfangen.
Und den Klassiker.
Ich habe hier noch so eine olle Elektroniksbox.
Und da gibt es...
Ich dachte, da sind eigentlich auch LEDs drin, wenn ich Glück habe.
LED-Champ.
Ja.
Und wir haben noch ein paar LEDs.
Guckt mal.
Wir haben sogar noch ein paar LEDs.
Da können wir...
Das machen wir als erstes.
Wir lassen es einfach mal blinken, okay?
Einfach GPIO an, aus.
Ich muss aber...
Ich muss was gestehen, Leute.
Auch wenn ich schon lange und auch, sagen wir mal so, semi-oft und viel gebastelt bin,
mit dem ESP32 als Plattform, vielleicht lassen wir die LEDs mal draußen.
Ich habe noch nie, das ist kein Witz, ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben
einen stinknormalen Blink-Sketch auf dem Breadboard gemacht.
Ja, wir haben schon den advancedesten Shit gemacht.
Selbstgebaute ZigBee-Sensoren, die jetzt bei mir im Stall hängen,
mit einem Temperatursensor dran und allem möglichen 3D-gedrucktem Gehäuse und alles Mögliche.
Aber so einen problichen Blink-Sketch, der ist ja nicht so einfach.
Ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben einen stinknormalen Blink-Sketch auf dem Breadboard gemacht.
Den Blink-Sketch habe ich noch nie gemacht mit dem ESP32.
Ja, noch nie, nicht nur mit dem ESP32, noch nie.
Das heißt, da brauche ich den High-IQ-Cute-Chat, der mir sagt, wie das geht.
Vermutlich ist es relativ einfach.
Wir suchen uns einen Ground-Pin und einen GPIO-Pin und das war's.
Oder braucht man noch irgendwelche Widerstände, Chat-Gil?
Wie ist das? Muss da irgendein Widerstand noch dabei?
Bei so einem
Braucht man wahrscheinlich nur für die Helligkeit, oder?
Warum liegt denn hier noch ein bisschen Lötzinn?
Ist das Lötzinn?
Widerstand ist sinnvoll
Was denn für ein
Kommt auf die LED an, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das für welche sind
So eine billig, egal
Dann vielleicht
Brennt die LED durch
Auch nicht schlimm
Keck Weight
5k, 1k
Ja, müsste ich alles haben
Probieren wir gleich aus
Aber als erstes
Würde ich sagen, müssen wir das Ding mal anschließen
Und so minimal flashen
Was passiert eigentlich bei diesen Dingern?
Wie gesagt, das ist frisch ausgepackt
Hat das vielleicht irgendein
Irgendein Beispiel
Sketch auf dem Display oder so?
Gucken wir mal kurz, ich schließe den mal an
Okay, er ist an
Guckt, seht ihr, es blinkt
Ihr seht, es blinkt, meine Kamera kann sich auch
Ja, Kamera
Alter
Ihr seht aber, es blinkt
Ah, guckt mal
Und das Display hat so eine Probe
So einen Demo-Sketch
RGB
Aber mit einem FPS nur
Okay, das Board und das Display
Scheinen offensichtlich
Zu funktionieren
By the way
Warum ist das jetzt auf grün stehen geblieben?
Man weiß es nicht
Wenn ich Reset drücke
Die Frage ist, welcher Reset ist
Scan Networks
Ne, ne, ne, das will ich nicht haben
Okay, whatever
Das werden wir jetzt gleich mal flashen
Nehmen wir doch das Kabel auch gleich
Als Verlängerungskabel für den PC
Aber bevor wir das flashen können
Müssen wir natürlich erstmal gucken
Wie wir so ein ESP32 mit Rust
Überhaupt
Ver-Hello-Worlded kriegen
Wobei, bevor wir anfangen
Würde ich sagen, löte ich mal schnell die
Ich gebe die Header
Die Pin-Headers dran
Das andere Zeug machen wir mal hier oben in die Ecke
Ja, Trick 17 übrigens
Wenn man
Ich mache mal hier das Kabel weg
Trick 17 übrigens
Wenn man solche Pin-Header dran löten will
Wir wollen das jetzt natürlich so rum machen
Dass wir oben das Display sehen
Dann ist es manchmal ein bisschen schwierig
Wie ihr seht, das hier gerade hinzubekommen
Ja
Oh
Und der Trick dabei ist
Man steckt die einfach schon ungelötet hier in so einen Breadboard rein
So, dass ungefähr der Abstand stimmt
Bin mir nicht sicher, ich denke mal so irgendwie
Oh, man steckt die schon so in das Breadboard rein
Ja, Abstand stimmt
Und dann
Mal gucken
Ne, Abstand stimmt nicht, stimmt nicht
Guck, ich habe es eins zu weit
Ich habe, ich habe es eins zu weit vorne gemacht
Nice, jetzt brauche ich erst einmal
Eine Zange, da ich es wieder rauskriege
Zu viel ist kein Problem, dann ist die halt dunkler, okay
Was?
Zangen Champ
Gucken, ob der Abstand jetzt passt
Ja, okay
So, guck, jetzt passt das Ganze
Können wir das mal festlöten
Und dann mal gucken
Und dran denken, LED, langes Bein ist Plus und kurzes ist Minus
Ach ja, es ist also nicht egal
Ja, das ist schon mal gut zu wissen
So, jetzt löten
So, und ja, weil jetzt ist das Gute
Ja, guck, man kann das jetzt gar nicht wirklich
Nicht wirklich schepp dran machen
Weil das
Sitzt halt einfach jetzt schon gerade drauf
Ich löte das mal schnell fest
Kommen wir kurz
Ich kann euch ein bisschen ranzoomen, wenn ihr wollt
Da haben wir wieder das übliche Problem
Wie wir das letzte Mal auch hatten
Dass ihr dann alles wunderbar seht
Aber ich nicht
Schauen wir mal, wie das heute klappt
Übrigens sehr nice mit der Kamera und dem neuen Objektiv, gell
Da erkennt man richtig was drauf
So
Wo ist denn hier mein
Kurz, Lötstation anschließen
Zack, anmachen
Lötzinn anschließen
Start
Yachibas, let's go
Also, wieder das übliche Problem
Ihr seht gut, ich seh schlecht
Aber ich hoffe
Funktioniert halbwegs
Ihr seht es, wahrscheinlich ein bisschen rauchen
Ah, das müssen wir schräg machen, sonst seh ich nix
Ja, das ist ziemlich doof nix zu sehen
Kann man das nicht vielleicht wenigstens ein bisschen so
Ein bisschen zu mir so machen, dass ich was
Kommt mal ein bisschen schlecht dran
Das ist ein bisschen klein, die Spitze ist ein bisschen groß dafür
Aber das kriegen wir schon hin
Jetzt hab ich nicht aufgepasst, waren wir hier hinten schon dran?
Ne, sieht nicht so aus
Aber sieht doch ganz brauchbar aus
So, andere Seite, mal abputzen das Ding
Sehr schöne, entspannende Musik dafür
Fast
Fast dran
Ja, man sollte es da nicht übertreiben mit so lange dranhalten, weil
Die Breadboards, die sind ja eigentlich auch nur Plastik, ja
Da muss man ein bisschen gucken
So, der 5V Pin
Den werden wir heute wahrscheinlich gar nicht brauchen
So, alles dran, lasst mal kurz gucken
So, kurz gucken, wie schaut das aus
Kamera, Champ
Kamera
Okay, der hat mal wieder keinen Bock
Ich denk, das ist ganz okay geworden
Von manchen bin ich mir nicht wirklich sicher, ob die gut geworden sind
Also, die Seite hier ist alles gut, ich mach mal wieder
Also, die Seite ist alles gut, bei der anderen bin ich mir da nicht so sicher
Ja, doch
Doch, doch, ich glaub, da ist alles dran
Ja, ich glaube schon
Da
Jetzt haben wir schön drauf
Facelink
Ja, good luck
Also, ich würde sagen, das passt, das sieht okay aus
Ich bin mir bei den unteren zwei nicht so ganz sicher, ehrlich gesagt
Also, bei den zwei hier bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, ob die richtig sind
Deswegen mach ich da gerade noch mal kurz
Bisschen was drauf
Ja, jetzt ist es okay
Jetzt ist es gut
Okay
Aus damit
Deckel raus
Zack
Weiter geht's
Also, da können wir mal anfangen
Bevor wir das Ding jetzt auf irgendein Breadboard stecken
Schließe ich jetzt bei mir mal einen PC an
Und wir flashen das mit Rust
Wobei, ich kann es ja im Prinzip hier auch liegen lassen
Dann kann ich gleich mal testen, ob die Verlängerung funktioniert
Ich hab hier nämlich irgendwo eine Verlängerung, so eine USB-Verlängerung
Ahem
Für genau so einen Fall
Ich hoffe, das reicht
Das könnte echt ein bisschen eng werden
Gucken wir mal
Wenn nicht, müssen wir irgendwie ein bisschen tricksen
Über den Raspberry Pi Tunnel oder so
Keine Ahnung
Ne, es reicht, es reicht, es reicht, es reicht, es reicht
Alles gut
So
Und
Jetzt hängt das nur so echt hier so ein bisschen auf halb acht rum
Müssen wir mal irgendwie so hier über den Tisch legen und so
Ja, so ist gut, so ist gut
Okay
Also hier haben wir unsere Kiste
Die
Darf ich mal so liegen
Hier was drauf, so
Perfekt
Die probieren wir jetzt mal, die probieren wir jetzt mal zu flashen
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert
Schauen wir mal
Dann attachen wir das erstmal
USB U8 Bridge
Das ist der ESP32
Gucken wir mal, ob der auch richtig connected ist
Sieht so aus, CTY USB
So, wie funzt das denn jetzt hier mit Rust und dem ESP32
Ja
Das ist ein ESP32 mit Display
Kann man ein bisschen ran zoomen jetzt, während wir hier sind
Muss ein bisschen Kameragramm
Usen
Wenn wir es schon haben, ja
Schauen wir mal, wie das Ganze funktioniert
Wie ist das denn gedacht?
ESP IDF Template
Gibt es da irgendeinen Guide zu?
Template for Hello World
Rust binary created for the ESP IDF
Based on Cargo Generate
This is great, you get me running Cargo new
Or if you want to mix Rust and C++
Want to mix Rust and C++
Nein, ich würde eigentlich
Ganz gerne einfach mal
Gibt es da irgendein Tutorial für?
Ne, ich habe noch nichts geflasht
Hier gibt es sogar ein offizielles Rust-Example
Von Espressif
Das sind die Hersteller von dem Ding
Ok
Prerequisites
Overview of the using standard library
Setting up development environment
Install Rust
Haben wir
Wir können es nochmal erst updaten
Rust up
Ne
Rust
Up
Rust up
Einfach update?
Update
Ok
Haben wir die aller aller aller aller neuste Rust-Version
Die ist von heute Nacht oder sowas
Install requirements based on your targets
Das brauchen wir
Cargo install
Ja moment
Das funzt, wenn ich das einfach so mache
Cargo install OSP
Im Leben nicht oder?
Mal hier, Temp
MKDia
ESP
Rust
Das funzt doch so im Leben nicht
Doch, echt? Wirklich?
Oh, das halbe Internet wird installiert.
Let's go. Wisst ihr was?
Wir machen mal vor dem ganzen
Krempel Snapshot.
Die Katze schaut zu. Excellent.
Da kann man nur hier sagen.
Ich habe heute meinen Vater
einen Computer vorbeigebracht.
Mit Linux Mint drauf.
Der verwendet jetzt Linux.
Weil der hat ja...
Dem habe ich ja meinen alten Computer gebracht.
So einen alten vom Dachboden. Da war Windows 11 drauf.
Und nach einem halben Jahr
hat er das so versaut, Alter.
Mit was da ein Scheiß drauf war, Leute.
Tune Up.
Cookie Security.
Es gibt irgendein Tool, das nennt sich
Cookie Security Blocker oder so.
Frag mich nicht, was ist irgendwas, was extra installiert ist.
Keine Ahnung, was der Typ da treibt.
Hast du ihm gesagt,
dass es nicht Windows ist? Weiß er. Ja, das hat er schon gecheckt.
Das hat er schon gecheckt. Das ist so blöd, ist er nicht.
Das hat er schon kapiert.
Und der benutzt bloß
einen Chrome. Was anderes hat er nicht.
Im Prinzip das Einzige, was ich heute
gemacht habe, ist
die komplette Festplatte von der alten Kiste
rübergezogen auf ein USB-Laufwerk,
das auf die neue Kiste kopiert
und seine Chrome-Passwörter
exportiert und im Chrome
unter Mint importiert.
Achso, ja, und ich habe noch einen Teamviewer
drauf, dass ich darauf zugreifen kann.
Das war's.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie gut das klappt.
So, jetzt haben wir das hier.
Install necessary toolchains.
ESP up install.
Ah, das ist jetzt nicht im Path.
Äh, ja, wie jetzt?
Ich habe das jetzt installiert,
aber wo ist das denn?
Das liegt bestimmt irgendwo in Cargo-Bin
oder so rum.
Warte mal, ich höre einen bei mir an der Tür.
So.
Mein Vater hat irgendwie seinen zweiten Bildschirm ausgeschaltet
und kriegt ihn jetzt unter Linux nicht zum Laufen.
Hahaha.
Ja.
Ich habe es euch ja gerade erzählt.
Ich gehe mal davon aus,
der hat ihn einfach nicht eingeschaltet.
Ich würde jetzt mit euch zusammen
remote gucken, aber das ist zu viel Leak.
Wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben?
Was wollte ich denn gerade machen?
Achso, genau, wo ist denn dieses...
Ich habe keinen SSH-Zugang, ich habe Teamviewer drauf.
Wo hat er diesen Krempel jetzt?
Ach, da steht es doch hier. Cargo-Bin.
Ich hätte eher Angst, dass er TOS...
Ja, ja, deswegen, ja.
Deswegen mache ich das nicht.
So, install necessary...
Necessary-Tool-Chains.
So, wir machen das jetzt mal so.
Wir packen das mal in den Path.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Packen wir das hier irgendwie dabei, ja?
Packen wir hier irgendwie Home.
Sowas hier...
Ne, Moment.
Cargo-Bin.
Wenn ich das jetzt neu starte, dann sollte ich eigentlich...
Ja, du zubringst das Falsche.
Rust.
ESP32, Rust.
Dann sollte ich jetzt eigentlich...
Wie heißt das Ding?
ESPPUB-Install.
Okay.
Installing Expressive Rust-Ökosystem.
Bis jetzt funktioniert der Guider-Network nicht schlecht, gell?
Standard Applications require install additional software covered in standard development requirements.
What?
Make sure you have the following required tools installed to build standard applications.
ESP, Python, JIT.
Ja, das haben wir.
Haben wir alles installiert.
Was?
LD-Proxy, Binary-Create.
Vielleicht kriegen wir das Hello World...
...auch so hin.
Hä?
Lass, lass mal probieren, ob wir ohne diesen ganzen Kremplern Hello World hinkriegen.
ESP-UP will create and export files that contain some environment variables requirement to build projects.
Okay.
Hier.
To get started, you need to set up your environment by running.
Okay, das müssen...
Das muss gesourced werden.
Okay.
Ja, das leuchtet mir ein.
Was ist da so drinne?
Ach so.
Okay.
Ja, Compiler geht durch.
Haben wir gemacht.
Ja, ja, passt.
Das haben wir jetzt.
Das haben wir alles.
Das haben wir auch.
Write your own applications.
Boah, alles, alles gut.
Generating.
Understanding Template.
Okay, was muss man jetzt machen?
Das ist etwas confusing.
Generating projects from templates.
Ach so, hier.
Was ist denn das da?
Moment, ich muss das Nose-Standard benutzen, oder?
Weil ich doch den anderen Krempel nicht hab.
Hello World.
Okay.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, ob wir das Low-Level Zeug zum Laufen bekommen.
Git clone.
Was würdest du mir empfehlen als Neuling?
Das kann man überhaupt nicht sagen.
Was interessiert dich denn?
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn du mich fragst, Max, ich kann ganz gut schwimmen.
Was empfiehlst du mir?
Webseiten erstellen.
Ja.
Webentwicklung.
Wobei man sagen muss, Webentwicklung ist auch so ein bisschen heißes Pflaster.
Das geht von ultra nervig und nicht viel Kohle zu mega nice und viel Kohle.
Also Webentwicklung ist ein bisschen Mienenfeld.
Habe ich zumindest persönlich den Eindruck.
Ich war noch nie Hauptberuflich in der Webentwicklung.
ESP Template.
So, und wie und was und wo und...
Ach so.
Cargo General.
Ach, das kann man einfach so angeben, oder was?
Ach so, ja, das hätte man sagen müssen.
Das muss man gar nicht klonen.
Dann löschen wir das jetzt nochmal.
Ja, ja.
Yes.
Cargo Generate ESP.
No such command generate.
Nice, das findest du ja schon richtig gut.
Ach ne, Moment, ich muss erst mal Cargo Generate installieren.
Okay, alles klar.
Webentwicklung ist ein Fass ohne Boden, wenn du das umfassend lernen willst, ja.
Ich meinte jetzt eher so Gehalt und Arbeitsbedingungen.
Ja.
Aber Webentwicklung ist, also da Schritt zu halten ist echt nicht ohne.
Du passt mal einen Monat nicht auf, schon hast du drei neue Frameworks am Start.
Oder Updates.
Eine schöne Sache bei JavaScript ist, dass die Leute, die sich um den...
Was macht der jetzt eigentlich, drei Stunden lang?
Irgendwas Compilen, ja?
Das die Leute, die sich um den JavaScript Standard kümmern, wenigstens sinnvolle Sachen machen.
sinnvolle Sachen machen und nicht so wie bei Rust, äh, nicht Rust, was laber ich, Rust, lul, Alter, äh, nicht so wie bei C++, nicht Rust, äh, wie bei C++, immer neues, wirres und undurchsichtigeres Zeug machen, benutze für das Programmieren Visual Studio Code, auch, auch, es gibt, glaube ich, keinen Entwickler, der ausschließlich einen Editor oder eine IDE verwendet, so, probieren wir mal, geht das jetzt, aha,
was, Project Name, Keckel, wir haben einen ESP, einen ganz klassischen ESP32, haben wir, Advanced Template Options, false, oder wollen wir mal true machen, yes, okay, wir machen mal true und gucken uns, true, lul, weh, und gucken uns an, was Advanced Template, Template Options sind, true, Enable Allocations, what,
okay,
okay, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung,
Wok, Wokwi,
okay, das ist tatsächlich zu advanced, die Advanced
Config, da verstehe ich überhaupt nicht, was die von mir,
wir lassen die, wir lassen die Advanced
Configuration mal weg,
TS ist TypeScript,
das ist nochmal ein Aufsatz
auf JavaScript,
was ich mache, guck mal bei mir auf
YouTube, Ausrufezeichen YouTube, wir haben
bestimmt irgendeinen Link auf YouTube,
ähm, guck mal,
äh, ja, das ist, glaube ich,
ein ganz gutes Einstieg,
wie,
die, jo, aber,
das, das ist ein gutes Video,
das ist vor vier Jahren, wobei, das gibt das
schon geupdatetere Sachen, ja,
du kannst auch bei mir auf YouTube gucken, ich habe jede Menge Videos
dazu gemacht, so was ich mache,
und auch zum Thema Ausbildung und so was,
ja, es gibt zum Beispiel,
äh, ja, eben mit dem
Noel habe ich ein Video drüber gemacht, war immer auf dem Channel,
ja, so was hier zum Beispiel,
ich habe, ich habe jede Menge, jede Menge
Videos gemacht, keine Advanced
Template Options, okay,
so, wie geht es jetzt weiter, jetzt haben wir es Generated,
Cargobuild,
jetzt gehen wir da rein,
und was, und dann sagen wir was, Cargobuild,
okay, der macht was,
du glaubst nicht,
dass es noch schlimmere Programmiersprachen als
C++ gibt, doch, doch, das glaube ich dir schon,
aber C+, also,
was mich ja an C++ immer so triggert, ist,
dass sie ja irgendwie
den Anspruch haben,
und da halt immer maßlos dran scheitern,
es irgendwie zu verbessern,
und logischer und konsistenter
zu machen,
dass, dass sie sich quasi immer weiter rein reiten
in das Ganze,
Restoring and using Release Profiles while building,
okay, Minus, Minus, Release,
wir bilden den Release, alles gut,
und jetzt Cargo run to compile
the project flashing on a serial monitor with
a target device, boah, das macht das alles
auf einmal, okay,
jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
ob das von uns
angeschlossen ist das,
Release, äh,
ESP Flash gibt es nicht,
ja, ESP Flash gibt es nicht,
weil ich keine,
aber das stand auch nicht in der Anleitung,
weil ich das, Moment,
ESP Flash ist wieder
was anderes, oder,
IDF, äh, genau, weil so hat man
das gemacht, dann muss man
ESP Flash nochmal zusätzlich installieren,
okay, run,
Moment, hat der jetzt ge...
Natürlich nicht,
oh, oh, es geht,
Leute,
das war jetzt,
Erstaunlich einfach.
So, und jetzt das Ganze natürlich noch mit der Rust-Standard-Library.
Ja, das ist auch nicht so easy.
Und die Sachen, die in der C++-Standard-Library drin sind,
lassen sich halt auch komplett unterschiedlich verwenden.
Habt ihr euch mal die C++-Chrono-API angeguckt?
Ich weiß nicht, wer sich gedacht hat.
Ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
Lass uns das mal so einbauen.
Ist mir komplett unverständlich.
So, und jetzt gibt es noch das Template mit Standard.
Das EDF-Template gibt es noch.
Okay, das probieren wir jetzt auch mal.
Project Name, Kekkel-EDF.
Da muss ich ja bestimmt noch irgendwas machen für.
Kekkel-EDF, Cargo-Build.
Das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Weil irgendwas fehlt.
Gut, Rust-typisch wird mir erstmal wieder das halbe Internet runtergeladen.
Und compiled.
Die Build-Times von Rust sind ja immer auch jenseits von gut und böse.
Aber immerhin ist das alles schön multithreaded.
Rustge, wie sieht's aus?
Post-Champ, macht der noch was?
Also wenn ich's nicht besser wüsste, würde ich sagen, der hängt.
Und ich weiß es nicht besser, also vermute ich einfach mal, der hängt.
Und man weiß halt nicht so genau, wo.
Der hat doch irgendwas hier geschrieben.
Standard Development Grades.
Linux-ESP-EDF, ja die haben wir auf jeden Fall da.
Die ESP-EDF.
Die haben wir auf jeden Fall da.
Weil wir haben ja ESP-EDF installiert.
Also haben wir die Prerequisites.
Der hängt, oder?
Nee, jetzt nicht.
Jetzt macht er doch was.
Guck mal, jetzt flutscht's.
Oder auch nicht.
Fuck, ich bilde das gerade mit Debug.
Jetzt muss ich das gleich nochmal mit Release bilden.
Dann dauert das nochmal so lang.
Ah, LD-Proxy not vorne.
Okay, ist gut.
Machen wir.
Wisst ihr, das ist ein Grund,
warum ich echt glaube,
dass C++ unglaublich von Extension-Methods profitieren könnte.
Dann könntest du nämlich die C++-Standard-Library einfach gut machen,
ohne dass sich das Gremium darum kümmern muss.
Und es muss nicht jeder seine eigenen String-Implementierung mitbringen und so ein Dreck.
Guck mal, das hat jetzt funktioniert.
Macht das jetzt was?
Ja.
Muss jetzt eigentlich gleich was futtern.
Aber das mache ich hier on stream.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Dann ist das jetzt fertig.
Und jetzt kann man Cargo-Build.
Ne, Cargo-Build haben wir gerade gemacht.
Cargo-Run.
Was haben wir denn jetzt hier überhaupt drinne?
Cargo-Sauce-Main.
Okay, da macht im Prinzip das gleiche.
Nur, dass man jetzt die Rust-Standard-Library verwenden kann.
Okay, Cargo-Run.
Jetzt wird geflashchamped.
Leute, MAC-Adresse liegt.
Seid ihr schon drin?
Alter, wie langsam.
Wie flasht denn der?
Da kriege ich ja Zustände, wenn ich bei jedem Flash-Vorgang so lange warten muss.
Da kann man doch bestimmt irgendwie Baud-Rate und sowas konfigurieren.
Irgendwo.
Hello World.
Okay, es hat funktioniert.
Hat funktioniert.
Nice.
Das tut.
Irgendjemand.
High IQ-Idee.
Wie man hier konfiguriert.
Wie der sich verbinden soll.
Zum ESP.
Mit ESP.
IDF.
Weiß ich, wie das geht.
Da setzt man nämlich einfach die Baudrate von dem Ding.
Aber wie macht man das hier jetzt?
Oh nein.
Leaked.
Schon wieder.
Die habe ich jetzt schon 500 Mal geleakt.
Nee, das ist nicht geleakt.
Das ist das hier offiziell verbunden auch, wo man früher auch was drauf spenden konnte und so.
Das ist eh bekannt.
Bevor jetzt einer wieder kommt.
Haha.
E-Mail-Adresse liegt.
Können wir jetzt anfangen.
Was gibt's für eine Müsli?
Ja, richtig.
Richtig.
Ich esse abends gerne.
Ich esse abends gerne Müsli, weil das vertrage ich immer ganz gut.
SDK.
Config.
Defaults.
Äh, ach, das ist nix.
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt sagen ESP.
IDF.
PIE.
Und dann, äh, wie ging das nochmal?
Äh, Config?
Nee, ich habe schon wieder vergessen.
ESP.
IDF.
Nicht BILD.
Äh, wie viel Zeug habe ich hier im Hintergrund?
Menü-Config.
Menü-Config würde ich normal machen.
Ja, aber das gibt es nicht.
Es gibt es ja hier nicht.
Okay.
Wie setzt man dann hier...
Jetzt bin ich echt...
Warte, für Target?
Nee, Target ist da...
Ähm.
ESP, ESP.
Baud.
Baudrate.
Baudrate. Flash.
Wie setzt man das?
Baudrate. Ignored.
Das setzt man in...
In...
Nee, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie man hier die Geschwindigkeit setzt.
Zumindest muss ich irgendwie die Geschwindigkeit setzen,
sonst kriege ich...
Ich krieg, ich krieg, ohne Scheiß, ich krieg komplette Anfälle, wenn ich jedes Mal das flashen muss.
Und guckt mal, wie lang das braucht.
Und es ist ja noch nicht mal groß.
Der, der, der, was ist denn da die Default Baud Rate?
Wie stellt man das jetzt ein?
Weiß ich nicht viel.
Flashing seems to be slower than expected.
6 Minutes, Alter.
Kannst du im Conf, in welchem?
Ah.
Das ist gut zu wissen.
Guck mal hier.
Und wo ist das Config File?
Ach, das ist nicht das Rust.
Doch, das ist das Rust.
The Configuration File.
Das finde ich ja auch immer geil.
Wo ist denn The Configuration File?
Vielleicht hier unter Source?
Ne.
Der Cargo-Tommel ist auf jeden Fall schon mal nett drin, ne?
The Configuration File.
Ah, hier.
Äh, for local, store the file on the current working directory on a, okay.
Also im Prinzip brauche ich einfach so einen ESP-Flash-Tommel.
Dann schreibe ich jetzt einfach sowas hier rein.
Geht das?
Run.
Okay, das scheint nur jedes zweite Mal zu funktionieren.
Das funktioniert.
Guck mal, der.
Oh, doch, guck mal.
Das ging jetzt schneller mit dem Flashen.
Ne, das hat einfach alles abgekackt beim Flashen.
Was hab ich jetzt hier gehabt?
Ich glaube, das ist zu schnell.
Ich.
Das hat nicht geklappt.
Oder?
Flashing has completed.
Ach, not changed.
Okay, ich muss irgendwas.
Ich muss irgendwas ändern.
Source, Main.
Hello.
Cute Chat.
Okay, Flash.
Chat ist jetzt schon schneller als vorher, oder?
Ja, gell?
Oder?
Ja, vorher hat das irgendwie 20 Sekunden oder so gebraucht.
Gell, das war jetzt schon schneller.
Wir können es ja nochmal umstellen.
Ups.
Machen wir das hier mal weg.
Machen wir das wieder rückgängig.
Und jetzt flashen wir es nochmal.
Also, eben hat es 8 Sekunden gebraucht.
Ja.
Das ist definitiv schneller gewesen.
So, ich muss mal kurz mein Müsli mischen.
Okay, ja.
21 Sekunden versus 8.
Schon ein Unterschied, ja.
Genau.
Eigentlich genau mein Gedanke.
Wenn das einfach funktioniert,
hat auch den Vorteil,
man muss auch nichts dokumentieren,
nichts kommentieren und nichts testen.
Weil es geht ja einfach.
Was ist denn das Doppelte?
9000 Irgendwas.
Okay, wollen wir mal gucken,
ob er das kann?
Gucken wir mal, ob er das abkann?
Guck mal hier.
Jetzt flutscht er aber.
Wie viel geht denn da noch?
Mal 3.
Okay.
Okay, ESP32.
W writes...
about...
81000.
Okay, okay.
Knights of the튼berg.
MaxCiMumBoardRate.
Ähm.
TT go T displayed,
dann muss man wahrscheinlich nach dem Board gucken.
Ah!
Buggt?
Nee, geht.
Komm mal hier, jetzt flutscht's.
Leute, 4 bis 5 Sekunden
versus irgendwie 23
oder sowas ursprünglich, weil das ist jetzt schon eine ganze Ecke schneller
mit dem Flashen.
Ich muss gerade mal mein Müsli reinhauen.
Das wird jetzt nix.
Da war ich schon nicht mehr.
Nee.
Etwas. Etwas zu hoch.
Einfach 5 mal höher als offiziell
supported ist vielleicht dann doch nicht
so sinnvoll.
Also das scheint echt der schnellste zu sein
mit dem man so flashen kann.
Aber okay.
Damit kann ich leben.
Machen wir das Ding mal in der IDE auf.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Wenn nicht Rider
importieren das, was dann dabei rauskommt.
Das wird doch im Leben nix.
So, ja, das ist Temp.
ESP
32.
Nee, nee, nee.
V-Max Temp.
Bester Ordnername.
Da weißt du sofort, was Sache ist,
wenn du das hier so liest.
0, W, 1, 2, 3, kek, W, kekel.
Sofort obvious, was dort Sache ist.
Trust Project.
Jawoll.
Hier hat das irgendeine Art von Autokomplikt,
dieses Ding jetzt.
Ich kann doch nicht mal Enter drücken
in diesem Ding, Alter.
Kann das sein, dass der Input komplett verkackt ist?
K-Map?
Keymap?
Wischel Studio.
Ah, jetzt funktioniert's.
Das ist schon mal nice.
Der erkennt alle möglichen Sachen.
Und auch mit Autokomplischen und sowas.
Schon mal ganz gut.
Dann ist die nächste Frage jetzt eigentlich.
Wir lassen mal.
Guckt mal hier.
Das Ding hat da doch eine LED.
Die können wir doch bestimmt sogar irgendwie ansteuern.
Aktuell
klingt die einfach nur sinnlos.
Aber die können wir nicht ansteuern.
wir garantiert irgendwie sinnvoll ansteuern die on board idee vorher noch nie was den rast gemacht
nicht so viel mehr aber doch bestimmt dann müssen jetzt gucken welche tp auch noch ein gps hier
drin aha das kann auch sein aber aktuell kommuniziert dann nichts und die blinkt
trotzdem wie verrückt die go t display led ok teilt to the battery circuit
was ist ein indikator sind indikator auf batterie betrieb oder nicht okay wir können
die led nicht ansteuern dann müssen wir tatsächlich eine eigene eigene led hier
mal aufs ans breadboard dran machen ja okay wie steuern wie
steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern
wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steuern wie steu
Wok wie?
Was zum Teufel ist
Wok wie? Hat das schon jemand mal gehört
von euch?
Wisst ihr was Wok wie ist?
Ein Online ESP32
Simulator. Ach so was.
Ach ja, nice.
Da kann man quasi
ohne dass man ESP32 hat
ein ESP32
programmieren. Eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Aber wir haben einen echten ESP32.
Source Main Hardware Check.
Ja, ist richtig nice.
Peripherals Take Unwrap
Sysloop ESP System Event Loop
Take
Whatever
Was für ein Ding
Wie heißt das Ding?
Äh, hallo? Ich will das Copy-Pasten.
Warum ist der neue GitHub Editor eigentlich so kacke?
Take
Und ein bisschen Docs wären geil.
Nice
Jetzt weiß ich voll Bescheid
was das macht.
Ihr bestimmt auch, oder?
Komplett obviously
klar. Event-Loop-Take.
Und das macht er vor Hello World.
Sysloop.
Benutzt er das irgendwie dann?
Aha.
Ach, das benutzt er später
für WiFi-Zeug und so.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Naja, er nimmt halt. Alles klar.
Jetzt weiß er Bescheid, oder?
Bail. Ist das sowas wie Panic?
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, das bringt uns nix hier.
Das Beispiel.
Ja.
Das ist das Beispiel mit
GPIO.
Äh, oh.
Und wo?
Okay, nice GPIO-Beispiel, ohne dass GPIO drin vorkommt.
Ach, nee, hier, das.
Ich hab das falsch auf.
Ich hab das falsch offen.
Das hier ist das.
Das ist das Example, oder?
Nee, nee, eigentlich
würde ich gerne ein GPIO.
Ich will kein GPIO-Interrupt.
Ich will nicht wissen, wenn einem GPIO was passiert.
Ich will einfach nur GPIO auf High und Low.
Low setzen.
Common.
Das ist zu, zu basic und obvious.
Das, äh, muss man nicht erklären.
Da steht gar nix drin.
Pin.
Button.
Ein.
Du willst kein Button.
Geht das einfach so?
Okay.
Nicht Button.
Start.
So.
Beste Ausgabe ever.
Let button pin driver.
Okay, ich, ich take hier jetzt irgendwas.
Leute, ihr werdet richtig, richtig, richtig getaked, was auch immer ihr das jetzt genau sagen soll.
GPIO.
Ähm, welchen GPIO haben wir denn hier schön, den wir benutzen können, klar?
GPIO achtund, äh, zweiundzwanzig.
GPIO zweiundzwanzig wird's werden.
GPIO zweiundzwanzig.
Äh.
Zweiundzwanzig.
Das nennen wir nicht, das nennen wir nicht Button, das nennen wir jetzt einfach hier irgendwie keine Output oder so.
Output, kann man das jetzt?
Ist ja ein Set, Set Level, aha.
Ich will auch vor allem, kein Input, sondern ein Output.
Set High, Set Low.
Excellent.
Okay.
Ja, dann probieren wir das doch mal.
Set High.
Ja, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall ne Schleife.
Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall ne Schleife.
Loop.
Ja.
Moin.
Sowas hier brauchen wir.
Loop.
Und jetzt, ich weiß nicht, wie man Delay macht.
Delay.
Sleep.
Sleep MS.
Ich bin mir unschlüssig.
Wie das, wie das von, zumindest von der Idee her, wollen wir Output.
Set High.
Wobei, das können wir weglassen.
Muss da, muss da, sollen wir da ein Simikon?
So, jetzt müssen wir Sleep 500 Millisekunden machen.
Und dann Output.
Set.
Low.
Ne, umgedreht.
Umgedreht.
Ne.
Ne, ist okay.
Was ist das, was ist das hier eigentlich gerade für richtig Hardcore Kokona Musik im Hintergrund?
Ist das Red Dead Redemption?
Das ist sowas von Kokona?
Hell yeah.
Ja, Red Dead Redemption, sag ich doch.
Hyper Kokona Music.
Erotile, danke für den Sub.
So, also im Prinzip wollen wir sowas machen.
Mein Problem ist nur,
ich weiß nicht, wie man es liebt.
ESP, ES, Delay, äh, Delay, was, Brie, Ertos, Delay MS, ah ja, ja, das ist gut, sowas will ich haben, 500 Millisekunden, easy.
Jetzt die Frage, ob das kompiliert, was ich hier gebaut habe.
Bild.
Das wäre jetzt natürlich in Rust auch viel zu einfach gewesen, wenn das einfach kompiliert würde.
Eeeeeeh.
Das ist die typische Rust-Geschichte, man.
Ich weiß, glaube ich, was es ist.
Das ist der Return-Type von meiner Main-Function, das er nicht mag.
Was?
Jetzt, jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Ich habe das doch hier aus dem Beispiel.
Anyhow Result.
Ah, guck mal.
Ich habe Result nicht drinne.
Was ist, was, was ist das schon wieder?
Result in Anyhow.
Hä?
Oh, Epona ist am Start.
Warum brauche ich für einen fucking Return-Type eine extra Crate?
Das triggert mich an Rust jetzt schon wieder.
So, kann man, kann man nicht einfach jetzt hier das fixen lassen?
Wie muss denn das jetzt richtig aussehen?
Okay.
Ganz, ganz...
Kann man das vielleicht einfach so machen?
Ich weiß, ich weiß nicht, was...
Ey, ich war immerhin gescheite Fehlermeldung, ja?
Error.
So was hier? Ne.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich mache.
Oh, was ist jetzt so?
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was ich mache.
Ich habe absolut keinen Plan.
Einfach Unwrap. Ja, das geht wahrscheinlich auch.
Unwrap. Bam.
Dann explodet es halt einfach an der Stelle.
Wenn es nicht geht.
Unwrap. Bam.
Unused Empor. Ja, ist mir egal.
Wobei das Event-Loop-Ding...
Wo ist es denn überhaupt?
So was kann gehen.
Okay. Moment.
Das probiere ich jetzt aus.
Wie soll man auf sowas... Ne, das geht nicht.
Wie soll man auf sowas denn als Normalsterblicher kommen, Alter?
Das wird jetzt unwrapped, alles.
Unwrap. Bam.
Okay. Run.
Also, wir haben ja noch keine LEDs angeschlossen, aber...
Okay.
Wir lassen den mal hier...
Wir schauen mal, ob der wirklich delayt, okay?
Das ist doch Mist, was ich mache, oder?
Ich muss so machen, oder?
Weil jetzt... Guckt mal, Leute.
Das ist ein Denkfehler, den man gerne bei solchen Schleifen hat.
Guckt mal, ich sage high, delay, low.
Und dann geht der instant wieder high.
Weil hier die Schleife wieder rumwrapped.
Ich muss wahrscheinlich so machen, dass das Sinn ergibt.
Und jetzt...
Loginfo.
Sagen wir jetzt hier einfach...
High, low.
Das war so Output-Aussehen.
Nee, der hat keine...
Der hat hier oben eine LED, guckt da.
Aber das ist nur für die Anzeige,
ob der die Batterie angeschlossen hat,
oder nicht.
Der hat keine Batterie.
Also das blinkt jetzt so bescheuert wegen
USB-Power.
Der hat keine Onboard-LED.
Dafür hat der, wie du vielleicht
noch nicht gesehen hast,
der hat ein Display auf der Seite.
Deswegen haben die wahrscheinlich einfach drauf verzichtet.
Das mit dem Display, das müssen wir dann noch probieren,
GPIO 22 ist es Chatge, da wollen wir mal, GPIO 22, warte mal, ich steck das mal so drauf, dass das irgendwie ein bisschen Platz da unten hat, warte mal, wo ist denn GPIO 22, da, da ist GPIO 22, da wo mein Daumen ist, könnt ihr es sehen, die Kamera hat es mit Autofokus gerade nicht so,
jetzt müsst ihr mir helfen, da bin ich echt der übelste Noob, ich habe zwar viel schon gebastelt, aber ich habe noch nie einen popeligen LED Blink Sketch gemacht, wo ist Plus und Minus, das kurze oder das lange Ende, hallo, scharf machen, please, lang Plus, kurz Minus, heißt, wir schenken uns jetzt mal den Widerstand,
Chat, was meint ihr, brennt es durch?
Brennt es durch, wenn ich keinen Widerstand dazu mache?
Es geht kaputt, sehen wir gleich, mal gucken, Alter, oh, was sind das für Beine bei der LED, man, ja, wir haben die LED auf 21 und da oben auf Ground, Ground ist noch nicht angeschlossen, das müssen wir jetzt noch machen, ich lasse es einfach hier unten stehen und zoome ein bisschen ran, dann seht ihr das besser,
jetzt brauchen wir noch irgendwie so ein kleines,
ja,
Kabelchen,
so ein graues oder so,
so ein ganz kurzes, haben wir noch ein ganz kurzes vielleicht,
so, und das machen wir jetzt zwischen Ground und,
ach komm, ich nehme so einen,
ich nehme so einen,
ich habe doch hier so ein,
so ein Teil,
so, Ground ist hier oben einer,
steht zumindest, steht zumindest,
geht ran,
so, das müsste doch von der Idee so funktionieren, oder?
Was ich da gebaut habe,
das ist 3,3 Volt,
also von der Idee,
Idee müsste das doch so funktionieren.
Hier oben, also ganz,
das Blaue ist ein Ground Pin.
Ground, Ground geht ja hier so durch.
Das ist, das ist
GPIO 21 da oben.
Du musst nur einen Widerstand machen, anstatt
dem Kabel. Okay, Chat,
ich mach das, wie ihr das sagt. Ihr habt recht.
Wo ist denn hier meine
Spezial-Elektronik-Box?
Was für einen Widerstand
brauchen wir?
Was haben wir denn hier?
100K ist vielleicht ein bisschen
viel.
Kann das jemand
erziffern, was das mal war?
Steht da 1K?
Oder stand da mal mehr?
Jemand, jemand von euch
so high IQ und kann dieses
Coding? Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
100?
1M?
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel.
10K hätte ich noch
zu bieten.
10.
100 passen, okay.
Chat, wenn ihr
das sagt, easy.
Gucken wir mal.
Ich mein, mehr als, dass die LED kaputt geht,
kann ja nicht passieren.
Ah.
Da sind wir.
Jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit.
Ob das Fund zwar schon gebaut hat.
Es leuchtet, Leute.
Aber es blinkt nicht.
Es leuchtet ganz
dunkel, aber es blinkt nicht.
Was sagt mir das jetzt?
Das sagt mir, dass ich irgendwas...
Dass mein GP, dass mein
ESP irgendwas nicht richtig macht, oder?
Mach mal ohne Widerstand.
Einfach nur mit dem...
Äh, sieht genauso aus.
Es ist im Prinzip kein Unterschied.
Leuchtet ganz, ganz, ähm...
Die Sache ist die.
Chat.
Nur weil dort 21 steht,
heißt es noch lange nicht, dass die
GPU Nummerierung stimmt.
Das kann auch sein, dass die
GPU Nummerierung nicht stimmt.
Das kann auch sein.
Das kann auch sein, dass die
die GPU Nummerierung...
Ich meine, so sollte jetzt gar nichts passieren, ne?
Ja, so passiert gar nichts.
Also das mit Ground scheint schon mal
zu stimmen.
Ich hab's grad ein bisschen verbogen.
Also das mit Ground scheint schon mal zu stimmen.
Seht ihr eigentlich, dass die LED angeht? Ja, ne?
Das sieht man schon von oben.
Ja, ja, das sieht man.
Es ist ja vielleicht gar nicht...
Auch wenn da 21
dran steht, ist das vielleicht
bei dieser komischen internen Nummerierung
ja gar nicht 21.
Das ist nicht, das ist nicht an
22 dran, das ist an 21 dran.
Das sieht von oben nur so aus. Guckt mal.
Das ist an 21 dran.
Im Programm war 22?
Hab ich 22 genommen?
Wirklich?
Ja? Na dann.
Hab ich echt 22...
Ja, Chat, ihr könnt euch
das besser merken.
Okay, guck mal, jetzt ist es auf 22.
Ha!
Es blinkt!
Im
500 Millisekunden Abstand!
Da wirst du ja
verrückt, ey.
Da kann man nur sagen...
Ja, der andere hat
ge... ist gefloatet.
Kein Wunder, dass das nicht funktioniert hat.
Aber es funktioniert, ja, nice.
Was hier gebastelt wird...
Ich baue einfach ein bisschen mit Rust
an dem ESP32 rum.
Da passiert gar nichts großartiges.
Einfach, um zu gucken, wie man
das mit Rust macht.
Wie findest du raus? Auf Low Levels
find das doch sehr anstrengend. Was?
Wie findest du Rust auf Low Levels?
Finde das sehr anstrengend. Ja, ich finde das auch anstrengend.
Auch wenn wir noch nicht
viel gemacht haben, aber
es macht einen anstrengenden Eindruck.
Aber Rust macht immer einen anstrengenden Eindruck.
Okay.
Was blinkt denn hier so? Guck mal, das ist die
LED, die ihr hier unten blinken seht.
Da unten.
Mal abkacken.
Das war jetzt aber insgesamt doch
erstaunlich easy.
Würde ich mal sagen.
Machen wir doch mal, Leute.
Machen wir doch mal den
Temperatursensor.
Temperatur-Luftfeuchtigkeitssensor.
Das ist eines,
also der muss in Rust gehen.
Das ist eines der verbreitetsten
Sensoren da schlechthin.
Das ist ein, sieht man vielleicht,
ein BME.
Äh, BME.
BMP-280.
Man sieht nichts, ne?
Kamera hat mal wieder keinen Bock gerade.
Naja. Es ist ein
BMP-280.
Das ist
also eigentlich eines der
verbreitetsten
Sensoren so überhaupt, was es
da so, was es da gibt.
Probieren wir den doch mal anzuschließen.
Müssen wir mal schauen, ob es da eine Library für gibt.
BMP-280.
ESP-RS.
Ist der?
BME-280.
Ah, das schadet mich nicht dabei.
Aber da gibt es doch eine Crate für, oder?
Was ist da?
Ich sehe, dass es mich manchmal verwirrt.
Ich finde hier meistens nicht.
Wo ist denn hier der Link zum Github?
Von dem Crate.
Das finde ich bei den Go-Docs
tatsächlich angenehm.
Moin Patrick, danke für den Sub.
Prok.
Fast 60 Monate.
Wo finde ich jetzt hier den Link
zum Github
von dem Typ?
Gar nicht.
Ah hier, genau.
Okay, wie findest du das jetzt?
Das ist ja für mich
nicht zu sagen.
Der Typ hatte ein Example.
Cargo.
BME-280.
Konnte man mit Rust Rover nicht
irgendwie sogar suchen?
Was man irgendwie sagen konnte?
Sucht das Package?
Nee, egal.
Cargo-Tommel.
Dependencies.
Konnte man?
Cargo-Ad war das, gell?
Oh, genau.
Da ist er.
Rates. IO.
Nee.
Gratis.
Suchen wir jetzt
BM-280.
Ja.
Link. Github.
Ah, da hat er auf jeden Fall ein bisschen mehr Sterne.
Da ist mir schon lieber.
Examples.
Basic.
Die Basics.
I2C-Bus.
Def. New. Def.
What? Was ist das?
Warum gebe ich nicht irgendwelche
GPIO-Pins an?
Ah, der ist vielleicht gar nicht explizit gedacht.
Der ist für Linux. Moment.
Ha.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Das ist für Linux.
Äh.
What?
Ach.
Dann ist das hier eigentlich nur...
Das ist ein Exempel, wie man den Krempel benutzt?
Oder...
Okay, das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen kompliziert gemacht.
Dann gucken wir uns mal das Exempel hier an.
Okay. Peripherals. Hammer.
GPIO-Pins.
Da müssen wir uns mal raussuchen.
GPIO-8, GPIO-9.
Sind die überhaupt
erreichbar?
Nee.
Sind sie nicht.
Wir können...
Wir können GPIO-12
und GPIO-13 nehmen.
Das ist okay.
12.
Das ist das schöne beim ESP32.
Da kannst du eigentlich alle Pins für alles nehmen.
Okay, so schon mal nicht.
Äh, ja.
Nice.
Haha.
Ähm, jetzt wüsstest du, wie man den Kram verwendet?
So nicht. Okay. Nice.
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, die...
...Config ist...
Also, das Beispiel ist nicht mehr aktuell.
Das ist sehr unpraktisch.
Ja, aber nahezu alle Pins.
Also, der ESP32 kann fast jeden Pin
Ice Currency machen.
Okay, Leute. Ich bin massive überfordert.
Was die überhaupt für mir wollen.
Ich meine, ich könnte einfach
die alte Crate-Version
benutzen, die der Typ auch benutzt hat.
Und dann hoffen, dass es funktioniert.
Weil das check ich nicht.
Das gibt's bei mir gar nicht.
Was die haben.
Ja.
Der C-Master.
Gibt's bei mir gar nicht.
Ich hab hier das drin.
Und dann hab ich...
Vielleicht muss ich auch New Primary machen?
Äh, echt kein Blasen.
Das funktioniert.
So, nochmal.
BMP 280, ESP S.
Das ist natürlich auch ein großer Vorteil.
Weil man einfach
die offiziellen Sachen macht.
Mit C und C++.
Da versteht man.
Ja, das haben wir schon.
Und dann haben wir hier
noch ein paar Spiele für.
E-Currency Driver.
Hä?
Nennen die ihre Library laufen?
Oder was? Das gibt's bei mir gar nicht.
Das gibt's bei mir gar nicht.
Wobei, hä? Doch.
Ich check's nicht.
Das gibt's nicht.
Dann was?
New. Ah, okay.
Ich hab absolut kein Plan, was ich hier mache.
So.
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Was ist das überhaupt?
Vielleicht kann ich einfach sagen
Config New. Äh.
Geil, es gibt so viel Configs.
Vielleicht soll ich das Using hier wegmachen.
Ich bin komplett lost,
Leute.
Was sie von mir wollen überhaupt.
Was soll ich denn hier als Option reinhauen?
Config. Ja, nice.
Welche Config?
Config.
Also, das ist der ernsthaft
beschissenste Autocomplete Intellisense,
den ich gesehen habe in letzter Zeit.
Und wenn du Autocomplete sagst, zeig doch mal
Config.
Ja, es ist nice, dass man da eine
Config braucht, aber
Config. Es gibt auch nur so wenige,
gell? Die da vielleicht?
Was jetzt?
Baut? Okay.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was der braucht.
100.
What? Was ist das überhaupt,
was ich da sehe?
Das ist ein Int mit Punkt
KHZ.
Also Kilohertz, aber
Hä?
Okay, I2C 0.
Der Autocomplete ist absolut nicht hilfreich.
Das da?
Ne. Und was hat der
Dude da eingebunden?
Das kannst du ja aber komplett vergessen, ja.
Achso, was ist das jetzt?
Okay.
Ja, das hat es aber immer noch nicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was der von mir will.
Hier sehe ich jetzt auch nichts.
Wo kommt das her?
Was der da eingebunden hat?
Ich hab überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, es scheint nicht
so kompliziert zu sein, wenn man das erstmal
angelegt. Was?
What the hell? Alter,
macht's noch komplizierter,
please, so einen fucking Sensor auszulesen.
Das Schöne ist, dass
das Beispiel so alt ist, dass die Library
schon wieder komplett anders aussieht.
Auch nice.
Ich meine, das, Config.
Wo kriegen die
dieses Punkt-Kilohertz her?
Für die Dateien?
Units? Hierher vielleicht?
Das heißt ja jetzt anders.
Das heißt jetzt so.
Jetzt Units?
100? Ne.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was der für
Value
New?
Ja, wie legt man das denn überhaupt an?
Rust ist echt eine Sprache, die ist nur
für absolut high-IQ-Leute.
Welcher Typ muss da rein,
Alter? Und wie benutzt
man ihn? Ach so, schau mal
net. Und New gibt's auch net.
Steht doch da.
Ha!
ZwinkerSmiley!
Ich check das net. Was wollen die von mir?
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das verwenden soll.
Herz U
für 64.
What?
100? So?
Ne.
Wie?
Alter, wie soll der Scheiß funktionieren?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Welcher Typ muss da rein?
Also meine Inns haben zumindest
schon mal keine.
Kein Overload mit irgendwie
Kilohertz oder sowas.
Das gibt's bei mir nicht.
Was?
What?
What the fuck?
Warum haben
die Dinger? Was zum?
Aber das hat immer
noch keine
richtige Überladung dafür.
Ist die IDE einfach nur Scheiße?
Wo ist denn unter? Ey,
keine Ahnung, ey.
Also, das ist jetzt
wirklich nicht in irgendeiner
Art und Weise
entwicklerfreundlich, was wir hier gerade erleben.
Okay.
Und wie geht's jetzt weiter?
Okay, hab ich jetzt? New Primary.
Okay. Ja, ja.
Okay, nice.
Sehr gut.
Das Fundst.
BME-Init.
Warum auch
immer da irgendein Delay rein muss?
Wisst ihr,
manchmal wär so ein bisschen
Aha.
Delay.
Mir ist nicht ganz klar,
warum man hinter den Init?
By the way, kann man
irgendwie diese IDE überreden dazu?
Einfach hier die Hilfe anzuzeigen dafür?
Wär doch sehr nice, oder?
Okay. In irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Delay.
Ach, das ist der
Delay-Typ.
Es gibt, es gibt
verschiedene, es gibt nicht, es gibt nicht, Leute,
es gibt nicht nur Sleep.
Es gibt Bettge-Sleep,
Sofa-Sleep,
Erdboden-Sleep,
hab ich schon, mag ich nicht.
Mehrere, mehrere
Sleepge-Bettge-Time.
So, Measure.
Alles klar.
Okay. Pocket.
Dann, dann machen wir das erstmal hier.
Measure.
Kann man das nicht irgendwie lock-in vormachen?
Okay, das wird jetzt nicht funktionieren.
Muss mal hier
mein, den ESP wieder
anschließen am Computer.
Connect to virtual machine.
Build.
Okay, immerhin. Run.
Ich weiß,
dass es noch nicht gehen kann, weil der ist noch nicht,
also hier der Sensor ist noch gar nicht angeschlossen, ne?
Geht mir nur darum, ob das Ding
jetzt nicht gleich crasht.
Ey, crasht.
Warum?
Rating I2C-Bus.
Sehr schön, nice.
Crasht der, weil nichts angeschlossen ist an den
GPIO-Pins? Vielleicht?
Oder weswegen crasht
er?
No acknowledgement.
Heißt das, weil da nichts angeschlossen ist?
Vielleicht?
Schwer zu sagen.
Das ist 402.
Okay, dann schließe ich das mal an.
Guck mal, ob das funktioniert.
Also, guck mal mal.
Was ist denn der Sensor?
Ist es ein 5 Volt oder ein 3,3 Volt Sensor?
Wahrscheinlich geht beides.
Ah ja, okay, geht beides.
Easy.
Also, machen wir mal.
Wir brauchen einmal
VCC
Moment, ich mach's ja andersrum dran.
Wobei.
Machen wir's einfach so rum dann.
VCC
Ground
Reicht das überhaupt bis da unten?
Dann
SCL
Und
Haben wir noch irgendwas, wo ungefähr genauso lang ist?
SCA
Okay, Ground
Ich mach mal ab kurz.
Ground
Haben wir hier schon.
Achso, das ist jetzt natürlich blöde, wenn ich das so mach.
Weil dann ist es falsch rum.
Dann muss ich das jetzt irgendwie
hier hin machen.
Das passt so nicht.
Machen wir mal eins weiter.
Denk an den Widerstand.
Ja, ist doch schlimm, wenn der noch dran ist.
Also.
Das Blaue ist
SDA.
Das Blaue ist SDA.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher.
Was haben wir in SDA genommen?
Das ist 13.
13 und 12.
Und das hier ist
VCC. Das kann ich sogar hier unten dran stecken.
Gerade so.
Gerade so, Leute.
Passt das? Reicht das?
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob ich's richtig angeschlossen hab.
Äh, hallo?
Sehr nice. Jetzt kann ich nicht mehr flashen.
Auch geil.
Ich kann bestimmt nicht mehr flashen, weil das Ding jetzt permanent crasht.
Da muss ich normalerweise
müsste man jetzt
die
Sensor abhalten. Äh, nicht den Sensor, den
Flash-Button.
Ich will das Ding monitoren, vielleicht auch ohne
ESP-Tool.
Moment, ich kann nur flashen und monitoren.
Ich kann nicht einfach sagen...
Okay, also das Ding wird auf jeden Fall immer noch weiter crashen.
Jetzt würde ja auch die LED und so funktionieren.
Unser Source-Code ist auf jeden Fall nicht
ganz so
richtig angeschlossen.
Müssten wir aber eigentlich alles haben.
Ich hab da bestimmt irgendeinen Mist drinne hier.
Ich hab halt absolut keinen Plan.
Hier crasht er.
T-T-Go, T-Display.
Was sind denn die Buttons?
Einer der Buttons müsste ein
Flash-Button sein.
Hoffe ich.
Der Ding hat keinen Flash-Button.
Der Boot-Button, ja? Den suche ich.
Aber der hat keinen Boot-Button.
Oder ist einer davon der Boot-Button?
Sieht überhaupt nicht so aus.
Disturbated wieder.
Normalerweise haben diese Boards
einen Button, wenn ich den halte,
geht der in so einen Spezial-Flash-Modus,
dass wenn der Controller die ganze Zeit
crasht,
dass der dann halt
in so einen Boot-Modus geht, wo man ihn flashen kann.
Oh, geil.
Sehr nice.
Machen wir mal den ganzen Krempel hier wieder ab.
Ach, guck mal, hier.
Das da wird der sein.
Hier.
Wenn man jetzt nur wüsste, ob man den halten muss, oder?
Ich glaube, jetzt ist er wieder der Disconnector.
Ah, okay.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall der richtige Knopf.
Das Ding crasht.
Bei...
I2C createn.
Was habe ich gesagt?
Ist SCA...
Ja, hier.
SCA 13.
STC 12.
Und VCC.
Aber das interessiert...
Äh?
Warum hängt der jetzt?
Verdächtig, oder?
Ich habe den direkt an der Stelle.
Machen wir hier einen Loop, oder so.
Das wollen wir mal wissen,
was da passiert.
Und...
Ah ja.
Egal wie das heißt.
So, flashen können wir das Ding jetzt nicht,
weil das aus irgendwelchen Gründen hängt.
Dann muss ich jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder
den hier gedrückt halten.
Den da dran machen.
Und hoffen, dass es
wieder flashbar ist.
Ah, das ist ja richtig kacke, ey.
Also wirklich, was machen will der nicht, gell?
Dann probieren wir das nochmal.
So wie ich es eben gemacht habe.
Also ich kenne das von anderen.
Du musst eigentlich diesen Button gedrückt halten, Strom reinstecken
und dann
kannst du
flashen wieder.
Wenn du Glück hast.
Aber anscheinend
haben wir kein Glück.
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Der kackt einfach immer ab an der Stelle.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe wirklich keinen Plan, wie das jetzt funktioniert.
Es ist ja auch nichts dran, was da gerade...
Also das, was da hier hängt,
hat nichts zu sagen.
Bautrade ist zu hoch, machen wir 100.
Echt ätzend, ey.
Doch, habe ich doch. Ja, guck.
GPR 12 und 13.
Man kann halt gar nicht richtig flashen.
Das suckt.
Was, die Bautrade beim Flashen ist zu hoch, meinst du?
Ja.
Kommt, das reicht auch, oder?
Ja, aber das ist eigentlich...
Okay.
Also, die ganze Zeit ging es damit.
Mal schauen, ob das tatsächlich was damit zu tun hat.
Okay. Crash, Crash, Crash, Crash, Crash, Crash, Crash, Crash.
Päh.
Ich habe nichts gemacht.
Das kackt nach einer Zeit einfach so ab.
Okay, aber zumindest...
Das ist schon mal gut.
Wir sehen.
Jetzt geht er.
War alles richtig.
Es war alles richtig.
Der Flasher war kaputt.
Ein bisschen hoch.
Der misst sogar die Temperatur.
Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit, Luftdruck.
Äußerst POG.
Oder?
So, dass wir hier natürlich jetzt Log-Info draus machen.
Dass es viel cooler aussieht.
Also, ganz zuverlässig ist das mit dem Flashen.
Aber alles irgendwie...
Dann doch nicht, oder?
Ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck,
der hat so ein paar Probleme.
Vor allem halt auch,
wenn man ihn frisch einsteckt,
dann geht er nicht.
Und...
Man muss den manchmal resetten.
Mit dem Boot-Button.
Aber wenn man den jetzt
flasht, dann geht das manchmal.
Nicht immer.
Aber manchmal.
Es ist ein TT-Go-T-Display.
Weil man damit schön viel ausprobieren kann.
Ich glaube, es liegt am
ESP32.
Vielleicht mag der das wirklich mit dem Widerstand
dazwischen nicht.
Vielleicht mag der das wirklich mit dem Widerstand dazwischen nicht.
Das kann ja schon sein.
Wir machen jetzt mal die LED raus.
Und...
Ich habe kein schwarzes Kabel mehr.
Doch, habe ich noch. Nice.
Und wir packen mal das Ground.
Ich sehe es nicht richtig.
Ground. So rauf.
Ohne diesen komischen Widerstand dazwischen.
Jetzt sehen wir halt nicht, dass er so schön blinkt.
Aber, whatever.
Wenn er jetzt...
Also, irgendwie
ist das Ding im Arsch.
Ja, der hängt im Main.
Das ist aber normal.
Das mit dem Flaschen sollte trotzdem funktionieren.
Hatte ich, ja.
Dass die LED nicht abkackt.
Aber das macht nichts.
Scheint es nicht zu sein.
Nehmen wir mal den Sensor weg hier.
Machen wir mal da Strom ab vom Sensor.
Dann...
Mag er auch nicht.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Aber prinzipiell scheint ja der Sketch zu funktionieren.
Weil wir haben es ja eben schon gesehen,
dass er auslesen kann.
Was?
Strom ab dem Sensor hast du so nicht?
Ich weiß.
Ich wollte den absichtlich, habe ich den abgemacht.
Guck mal. Irgendwas ist da echt
weird champ.
Mit dem Flaschen. Jetzt crasht er.
Pass mal auf, wenn ich den jetzt wieder anschließe,
dann crasht er nicht mehr.
Easy. Jetzt crasht er nicht mehr.
Jetzt funzt er einfach.
Ne, die Baudrate ist übelst...
Übelst klein eigentlich sogar mittlerweile.
Der hat irgendwelche Probleme
mit den Pins.
Vielleicht liegt das daran,
dass ich hier den, dass ich
Pin 12 und 13
benutze oder so.
Weil das auch wenig Sinn macht.
Beim ESP kannst du mehr oder weniger
alle Pins, also fast
alle Pins für I2C benutzen.
Also im Prinzip geht das Sketch.
Ja, man weiß aber halt nicht
was er
hat.
Es wäre ja nice,
wenn ich mich dahin
ver...
Weißt du was wir jetzt machen?
Export.
Ja.
EDF Pi.
Monitor.
Ich glaube Ketten kann man das nicht.
Ich würde das Ding gerne monitoren,
ohne dass ich immer flashen muss
davor.
Es muss doch irgendwie gehen, oder?
ESP Flash. Monitor.
Geht doch.
Aber sogar das monitoren timeoutet.
Also irgendwie hat das Ding
Schmerzen, wenn das angeschlossen ist.
Wobei ich glaube nicht, dass es daran liegt,
dass der Sensor überhaupt angeschlossen ist.
Sondern,
machen wir mal hier ab.
dass der,
die Firmware da irgendwelche Schmerzen hat.
Guck mal,
jetzt ist sogar, jetzt ist sogar der Sensor ab.
Aha, jetzt gehts mir.
Ich mein, der darf,
der darf gerne abkacken jetzt.
Na, jetzt kackt er ab.
Ja, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Äh, Flash?
Ey, wie ging das jetzt? Run?
Guckts euch an.
Das geht irgendwie gefühlt von
50 Mal
1 Mal oder so.
Ne, jetzt gehts öfters.
Das sind, ne, das sind keine Firmware-Probleme.
Also das ist in der Tat blöd.
Es scheint irgendwas hiermit
zu tun zu haben mit meinem
Krempel, den ich da gebaut hab.
Ich weiß aber nicht was.
Kann nicht sein, das ist an den SDA-Pins
nix mal dran.
Und das kommt über USB,
ne, ne, ne, das geht schon.
Kannst diesen Sensor einschließen,
da dran, Dinger brauchen fast nix.
Wobei, guck mal, wenn der Sensor angeschlossen,
wenn der Sensor nicht angeschlossen ist,
wie machen die das denn hier?
Haben wir noch andere GPIOs,
die wir benutzen können? Wir haben doch noch hier,
was haben wir denn noch?
Ja, machen wir das jetzt.
Ground.
Äh, wartet mal.
Muss das Ding mal abmachen.
Können ja mal.
Wir verbinden das jetzt mal direkt.
Ground.
Da machen wir jetzt hier
SDA
SDL 37
und 3,3
Volt da oben.
Gucken, ob der jetzt irgendwas
macht, weil ich mein, der sollte immer noch weiter crashen.
Ey, sobald das Ding
angeschlossen ist, der Sensor mag der nicht.
Das ist schon weirdchampig.
Äußerst weirdchamp.
Jetzt mag er wieder.
Mag er, mag er nicht.
Mag er wieder nicht.
Also da, das ist mir zu doof jetzt.
Okay, was hatte ich,
SDA
und das ist 37.
Äh,
wie jetzt?
Darf man das nicht
verwenden, oder was?
Was haben wir denn uns noch zu bieten?
25 und 26.
Darf man das da?
Ist das erlaubt?
Okay, push.
Calvo.
Die offiziellen? Keine Ahnung.
Nein.
Welche die ich da
glaube ich nicht habe.
Da sind die Default Dinger, das ist egal.
21 und 22.
Die habe ich glaube ich gar nicht hier draußen.
Ach doch,
21 und 22.
Die hatte ich doch, hatte ich die nicht sogar
vorhin benutzt, 21 und 22?
Die hatte ich, die hatte ich glaube ich
sogar vorhin.
Geht nicht, weil?
Achso, weil da schon
die LED dran war.
Dafür ist Rust natürlich nice
mit sowas.
Das muss man denen echt lassen.
Dass sie sowas
zur Compile Time erkennen.
Was ist Porg?
Laut der Website ist nur 21.
Das kann ja schon mal überhaupt nicht sein,
weil es auf anderen Ports funktioniert.
Das sind die Default Ports.
Ja, aber du kannst
du kannst bei einem ESP32 nahezu
jeden Port dafür verwenden.
So, was hat er mir jetzt gesagt?
SDA ist 21.
Okay, machen wir das doch mal.
Ja.
Das hatten wir eben schon mal.
Das hatten wir eben schon mal, aber
ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt
wirklich funktioniert.
Aber ich würde sagen,
das funktioniert ja.
Dann legen wir jetzt mal
die LED, was habe ich als nächstes
hier noch frei?
Ich will die LED da wieder reinpacken.
Einfach weil es,
ach ihr seht das gar nicht richtig,
einfach weil es netter aussieht.
17, 17 ist das nächste.
17, dann machen wir
jetzt mal hier
LED 17.
Und anstöpseln.
Nicht gut ohne Widerstand.
Ja, scheiß drauf.
Wie heiß wird denn das so?
Juckt das überhaupt nicht.
Okay, das funzt jetzt.
Das funzt jetzt in der Tat
ganz gut.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, was wir gemacht haben.
Und dass das
Flaschen ab und zu noch timeoutet.
Gibt es ein Wendler Emote?
Gibt es, haben wir.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ein Wendler tatsächlich ziemlich
ist.
Es funzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen jetzt besser
als vorher. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
warum, aber jetzt schlägt nur jeder zweite
Flash-Vorgang fehl.
Also ich, soweit ich das jetzt gesehen habe,
Leute, ich bleibe dabei.
Es ist cool, dass es Rust gibt
auf dem ESP32.
Und ich bin beim besten Willen
kein C++
Freund.
Aber ich glaube dadurch, dass
die offizielle Entwicklungsplattform
halt nun mal
C und C++ ist.
Und was Library-Verfügbarkeit
und Examples
angeht,
ist wahrscheinlich nach wie vor
C,
C++.
Kann man sich aussuchen, ja.
Also in dem Fall, ich sage es absichtlich zusammen.
Weil
ESP-EDF, die ESP-Standard-Library,
die ist komplett,
aber du kannst
vieles in C++ machen
und das ansprechen.
Und das ganze Arduino-Zeug ist in C++.
Also ich glaube,
man fährt trotzdem mit
C++ in dem Fall besser.
Weil es doch schon sehr kryptisch
an manchen Stellen ohne irgendwelche
Docks ist, so zum Beispiel das hier.
Ja gut, wenn man es
jetzt weiß, ist es okay, aber
allein schon, dass man dann unter
Also was mich ja auch getriggert hat,
ist, dass
ein Overload angeblich hat, aber meine IDE
das nicht anzeigt.
Da kann jetzt
die Entwickler von dieser ESP-Library
nichts für.
Es ist, ich glaube, es ist
mega nice,
wenn man
damit was wirklich
so Enterprise-
mäßiges bauen will.
Und dementsprechend auch
die Leute und die Zeit
reinstecken kann und wo man halt drauf
angewiesen ist, okay,
ich will das halt möglichst memory-safe machen
und möglichst stabil.
Das Ding ist halt meistens
ist das auf dem Microcontroller
gar nicht so wild, weil im schlimmsten Fall
crasht das Ding. Da kommt es halt
jetzt auf den Einsatzzweck an.
Weil das ein super wichtiger
hochverfügbarer Einsatzzweck
ist, ja. In irgendwelchen Maschinen
in der Fabrik willst du nicht haben, dass
das Ding ab und zu mal crasht.
Oder im Flugzeug oder
SpaceX, wenn sie zum
zum Mond fliegen, wobei die fliegen auch
mit Javascript zum Mond.
Also da mag das vielleicht Sinn machen,
aber so für unsere Heimatomatisierungsprojekte
und sonst was,
ich glaube man fährt immer noch mit C++ besser
für den ESP.
Der rebootet automatisch nach dem Crash.
Du kannst gar nichts dagegen machen.
Wobei,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das Gegenteil nicht vielleicht
einstellen kann, so nach dem Motto
Hold on Crash oder so.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das geht.
Ich glaube der rebootet
Bei einem Crash, der rebootet
immer bei einem Crash.
Der panikt dann,
schmeißt dir auf dem
Standard-Log-Output irgendwie so weiter,
kommt noch irgendwelche Traces raus und rebootet.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es überhaupt
irgendwelche Settings gibt, dass der nicht rebootet
bei einem Crash. Wo soll man Toast-Pot
noch futtern?
Der Arduino-EDE hängt da.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich an der Arduino-EDE.
Ich mag die Arduino-EDE aber
auch nicht.
Naja, jetzt habe ich es gesagt, lieber C++.
In diesem einen Spezialfall.
Arduino-EDE,
keine Ahnung.
Bei Arduino könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass sich der
Serial Monitor in der Arduino-EDE
irgendwie aufhängt.
Was ich viel lieber benutze ist, wenn es
einfach sein muss, Plattform-IO.
Es ist einfach komplett überlegen
der Arduino-EDE.
Oder,
was ich in letzter Zeit gerne mag,
ist tatsächlich
ISP-EDF
direkt
auf CLI.
Und wenn man Arduino-Sachen braucht,
Arduino als
ISP-EDF-Component.
Haben wir auch letztens im Stream gemacht.
Ist glücklicherweise seit der
letzten Version, wo sie den ganzen Camper gefixt haben,
ziemlich einfach.
Und es hat den Vorteil,
du kannst vieles
einstellen, was
wenn du rein Arduino verwendest,
nicht einstellbar ist.
Zum Beispiel die CPU-Frequenz
von deinem ISP.
Oder welche Extralibraries
du aus ISP-EDF verwenden willst.
Zum Beispiel hat der Web-Server
der ISP-Web-Server
in dem
wenn du nur Arduino verwendest,
standardmäßig keine Möglichkeit
HTTPS-Verbindungen zu handeln.
Kann man einstellen über eine Config,
aber die Config kannst du nicht ändern.
In einem reinen Arduino-Projekt.
In einem normalen
ISP-EDF-Projekt
mit Arduino quasi als Komponente geht das.
Ja.
Warum genau hast du mir das jetzt gepostet?
Du meinst, dass ich nicht Unwrappen muss?
Achso. Ja, du hast recht.
Ja, ja, du hast recht.
Aber
in dem Fall ist Unwrap
wahrscheinlich noch das Beste,
weil ich will
Temperatur auslesen.
Und wenn Temperatur auslesen nicht geht,
was will ich weitermachen, ja?
Da kann er ruhig crashen, ist ja okay.
Ja, normalerweise
das Ding hat keinen
Graceful Shutdown.
Es gibt keinen Shutdown.
Selbst wenn eine Main-Loop
endet,
crasht er.
Wenn der Main-Task sich beendet, crasht er.
Es gibt keinen Gracefully Shutdown.
Unsafe,
Unsafe, ja, Unsafe-Code
kann man ja jede Menge verwenden hier, aber
wisst ihr jetzt nicht was?
Ich hoffe, die fliegen damit nicht zum Mond.
Wobei, wie gesagt,
SpaceX fliegt auch mit JavaScript zum Mond.
Den traue ich alles zu.
Ja, MonkaJavaScript.
Hatten wir da nicht auch mal?
Hey,
wo ist unser JavaScript
MonkaS-Typ hin?
Oh ne,
Keck-JavaScript hatten wir.
Ja? Wenn du mir nicht glaubst.
Elektron ist das.
Vermutlich.
Es ist irgendein browserbasiertes Webinterface
hier.
Ich weiß
auch nicht, was mit denen los ist.
Wie warm ist denn die LED so?
Ach, nix. Das juckt die überhaupt nicht.
Woher weiß man bei AliExpress,
dass der
ESP, den man
sich kaufen will, kein billiger
nachgebautes Ding ist? Gar nicht.
Das ist AliExpress.
Aber macht dir nicht so viele Gedanken.
Die meisten Nachbauten
sind vollkommen okay.
Es gibt so ein paar Spezialfälle,
wo so Edge Cases
nicht richtig funktionieren.
Zum Beispiel
NodeMCU Nachbauten
auf AliExpress
die einen anderen Spannungswandler
benutzt haben
am Eingang
und die offizielle NodeMCU Doku
hat gesagt
Input Voltage 3,3 Volt
bis
12 Volt
Die haben das dann immer runter geregelt auf 3,3
oder 5 bis 12 haben die gesagt.
Input Voltage 5 bis 12 haben die gesagt.
Und die hat das immer
runter geregelt auf 3,3.
Und manche
billigen AliExpress Nachbauten
von den ersten NodeMCU Boards
hatten einen anderen Spannungswandler
und die sind bei allem, was mehr als
5 oder 5,56 Volt war
halt abgeraucht.
Das fällt dir aber nur auf, wenn du das
auch wirklich probierst, weil
normalerweise macht ja eigentlich kaum
jemand mehr als 5 Volt Input.
Aber manchmal ist das ganz praktisch.
Zum Beispiel habe ich im Keller
ein Netzteil
mit 12 Volt.
12 Volt Netzteil
wo ein paar Sachen angeschlossen sind
unter anderem zwei Kabel
die durch die Wand gehen in ersten Stock
und in zweiten Stock
und dort Tablets laden.
Vor den Tablets selbst
ist noch ein 12 Volt auf 5 Volt
USB
so Zwischenstecker
Zwischenstecker
aber
ist halt cool, wenn man einfach an das Netzteil
dann noch
zusätzlich ein
Stecker machen kann.
12 Volt für irgendwie
beispielsweise
irgendwas was du im Keller brauchst.
Das wollte ich damals bei den NodeMCU Boards
machen, habe festgestellt, oh das raucht ab
wenn du das mit 12 startest, weil es ein billig
AliExpress Nachbau war.
Aber ich wäre selbst bei dem Original
ein bisschen vorsichtig, weil
das ist wirklich so die
obere Ende der Sache, die die freigeben
der wird wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich heiß
der Spannungswandler. Also am besten
tatsächlich, man betreibt diesen Ding auf
VIN
nicht mit mehr als 5 Volt.
Dann wird das intern runter geregelt auf
3,3 für den ESP und dann ist gut.
Ja das ist normal.
Ach echt?
Also das habe ich schon gemerkt
dass wenn man
Warenlager EU und Deutschland
und Frankreich nimmt, dass es weniger ist.
Oder meinst du jetzt allgemein?
Das ist mir
noch nicht aufgefallen.
Was das da bedeutend weniger geworden ist.
Die Chinesen scheißen noch da in der Regel
so gut wie alles.
Was es an Regulatorien gibt.
Die sagen kek alu
die Germans.
Was ist mit denen los?
Was wollen die für Dinger?
Was können wir irgendwo drauf faken, dass sie sich zufrieden geben?
Wisst ihr?
Das ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen.
Und ich habe schon den größten Bullshit bestellt auf AliExpress.
Ich habe sogar eine
RGB LED Hausnummer
bestellt.
Okay.
Kann schon sein.
Kek W.
Okay Leute.
Genug gebastelt für heute.
Mir reicht das mit dem Display.
Probier mal andermal aus.
Das schaffe ich heute geistig nicht mehr.
Wir hören uns die Tage.
Ich hoffe entspannter Feiertag
gewesen heute.
Ich muss morgen wieder arbeiten.
Aber nicht schlimm.
Nicht so viel Action zu erwarten morgen.
Ne habe ich nicht.
Echt gibt es Bundesländer
die das nicht als Feiertag haben?
Dachte in Deutschland.
Weil es so ein christlicher Feiertag ist.
Wir haben noch ganz viele christlichen Feiertage.
Alles klar.
Wir hören uns.
Bis dahin machts gut Leute.